[Musique]
promener car partout dans plantation
sinon ça ch mais allez pas jamais dans
la accident làb Mad en a fait un
P
[Musique]
allez j pas de
bê les
filles allez cherche
la jardin
Maor faut pas ton Doig sinon va finir en
[Musique]
pas dans le jardin
maorette faut pas mettre t main sinon
toi finir
en dans le jardin Mar
Laurette fa pas ton pi sin va
finir
mais très désobéissant un petit
ravageur
cour tout juste à côté jardin de
Monsieur et là il se glisse sous le
[Musique]
portail
C
r
[Musique]
chff Krum Kum
Kum Krum Kum
carotte carotte
carot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
souffle
le
[Musique]
kumumumumum
laumum bom bom C trou et
[Musique]
sonou mon
V BES un peu
per on dit que le persil soig les m de V
pour moi je sais pas je suis pas un la
l'histoire il cour ch
[Musique]
mais il sur
monurter
[Musique]
đ
il cour dans T les s
il dans
[Musique]
il les gros boutons de sa veste se coin
dans les maill du filet ne peut pas' dép
alorsier abandonne sa derrière
lui
é veste là tu as une jolie veste toute
neuve avec de gros boutons de cuivre ouh
là là une veste beigge sinon ça on peut
dire chocolat au bon chocolat
blanc ah oui c'est toi oui ben tu sais
moi ça me fait penser à mon
grand-pèreille d' est trop trop trop
Gillant ah
ouiz là làand tu fais çaavoir une
exactement comme ça regarde E
l'istoireoire Pierre Lapin P courage il
tombe en
lar mais des oiseaux entendent ses
sanglot et viennent se poser là tout
près de
lui lauseou ple
pas besoin ou la
M allez
voir
allez
voir a tout le temps
chemin quand crois oou la
peur quand croit O est tout
seul allez voir
allez
voir nana Toutant
[Musique]
chemin lave pas le corère ti bon
enère lave pas le corp pièreou les la mê
lave pas le cor pierre ti bon ensemble
pierre pas le cor pierreou la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même d'un coup monsieur Maor débar il
tient à la main unille pour capturer
Pier alors saute dans la cabane à
routil